[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de historia de
france 24 mi nombre es álvaro cordero la
victoria de gustavo petro en colombia es
un triunfo histórico para la izquierda
en este país una hazaña muy complicada
en una nación que nunca había tenido un
gobierno de esta ideología pero que es
lo que no había permitido a la izquierda
llegar al poder desde el siglo 19 el
sistema político colombiano estuvo
dominado por liberales y conservadores
un establecimiento donde la violencia
reinó en varias ocasiones y donde las
voces de cambio siempre fueron vistas
con recelo la primera de estas voces
diferenciales fue la del caudillo
liberal jorge eliécer gaitán un político
que tenía especial sintonía con la clase
trabajadora su popularidad fue en
aumento durante la década de 1940 hasta
postularse como una opción real a la
presidencia pero el 9 de abril de 1948
fue asesinado por tres disparos su
muerte conmocionó a bogotá miles de
personas salieron a las calles
enfurecidas para protestar contra el
atentado una revuelta popular sin
precedente es conocida como el bogotazo
que arrasaría a la capital en apenas
unas horas y que terminaría con la vida
de entre 500 y 3000 personas la
violencia se replicó por todo el país
durante años y cesaría sólo con un
acuerdo político entre liberales y
conservadores
los pactos de benidorm del año 1956
supusieron la creación del frente
nacional entre estas dos formaciones
políticas cuyo único objetivo era
turnarse en el poder de forma pacífica
pero también supuso la marginación de la
izquierda de la política una decisión
que traería consecuencias durante el
período en el que estuvo vigente este
frente nacional entre 1958 y 1974 se
crearon cuatro guerrillas las fuerzas
armadas revolucionarias de colombia farc
en 1964 el ejército nacional de
liberación o ln en 1965 el ejército
popular de liberación o pl en 1967 y el
movimiento 19 de abril en 1973 más
conocido como
grupos que cada vez tendrían más
protagonismo durante las décadas
siguientes el conflicto armado se fue
reproduciendo y el poder de estas
guerrillas sobre vastas regiones del
país fue aumentando esta cuestión hizo
que inevitablemente la sociedad
colombiana empezara a relacionar
cualquier tipo de movimiento de
izquierdas con la insurgencia armada y
que el rechazo hacia estas aumentará
llegando a crearse grupos paramilitares
financiados por los grandes
terratenientes del país cuyo objetivo
inicial era la lucha contra estas
guerrillas la situación hizo que los
sucesivos gobiernos liberales y
conservadores se vieran obligados a
dialogar con estos grupos con el
objetivo de poner fin a la violencia y
garantizar su integración en la política
especialmente a partir de la década de
es así como en 1985 surgió la unión
patriótica una formación política que
era parte de una propuesta de paz entre
el gobierno de belisario betancur y las
farc o como en 1990 el m-19 se
constituyó como partido tras la firma de
una de paz con el gobierno de virgilio
barco
el acercamiento
con betancourt ha sido posible
porque en el parlamento se logró aprobar
una ley de amnistía
en la que nosotros hemos considerado
como muy importante como un primer paso
para entrar a solución son los muertos
los problemas que tenemos sin embargo
estos acercamientos no trajeron mejoras
aunque estos nuevos partidos trataron de
incorporarse a la vida democrática sus
líderes fueron perseguidos y asesinados
durante años por los grupos
paramilitares y por las fuerzas del
estado asesinatos a candidatos
presidenciales como jaime pardo leal y
bernardo jaramillo de la unión
patriótica o carlos pizarro del
movimiento 19 de abril marcaron a la
política colombiana
magnicidios a los que se sumó en 1989 el
de luis carlos galán un miembro del
partido liberal que aunque no tuvo un
pasado guerrillero también fue tiroteado
por tener un pensamiento más progresista
pero esta persecución no tuvo solamente
como objetivo a los líderes también a la
militancia de base numerosos políticos y
activistas fueron señalados durante los
80 los 90 y los 2000 de hecho la
persecución a la unión patriótica dejó
cinco mil 733 víctimas en apenas unos
años y es considerado por la edición
especial para la paz de colombia como un
genocidio político
vargas
esta cuestión en cristo el conflicto y
aunque el gobierno de andrés pastrana
trató de negociar con las farc en 1999
estos acercamientos finalmente
resultaron fallidos ya que durante el
tiempo de distensión las guerrillas
aprovecharon para reorganizarse y
rearmarse en lugar de apostar por la paz
una situación que degeneró en más
violencia y llevó a álvaro uribe a la
presidencia en 2002 durante su mandato
se optó por un enfrentamiento frontal
con las guerrillas que produjo un
aumento de las víctimas pero que también
hizo que estos grupos armados perdieran
fuerza en los años siguientes se
produjeron nuevos acercamientos que sí
terminaron en la histórica firma de un
acuerdo de paz con las farc en 2016 un
acontecimiento que sacó de la ecuación
política de colombia al conflicto armado
vivido durante las últimas décadas algo
que ha beneficiado a la izquierda ya que
ha visto como su presencia parlamentaria
ha crecido a pesar de que durante los
últimos años la derecha ha dominado el
gobierno en colombia' posturas como la
defensa de la paz y de un sistema
político más plural convencido a
millones de colombianos especialmente
cuando observaron que esa paz era
posible aunque fuera de forma parcial
motivos que sin lugar a duda han
contribuido al histórico ascenso a la
presidencia de gustavo petro en 2022 con
esto concluimos gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]